marine corps lieutenant colonel stuart
sheller pled guilty today to six charges
of violating the uniform code of
military justice
now as part of the plea agreement
sheller will resign his commission he'll
also receive a punitive letter of
reprimand and he faces a maximum
punishment of forfeiting two-thirds of
his pay
for 12 months that's a lot of money for
him
now what's important here is that
scheller is taking full responsibility
for his actions he pled guilty
the same can't be said for the
incompetent military leaders sheller
called out in the first place
joining me now is tony busby lieutenant
colonel sheller's attorney tony
um the military judge is considering all
of this overnight
what are you expecting from him in the
way of punishment
i believe based on what was presented
today that we're looking at a
a letter of reprimand
separation from the marines
and
likely a
a general discharge but we're hoping for
an honorable discharge
like you said
lieutenant colonel sheller is
took accountability as basically being
punished for speaking the truth
we wrangled and wrangled as you might
imagine
about whether we could so-called fight
these charges but
the lieutenant colonel made the decision
that he would be accountable for his
actions and we're all still wondering
when the general the general officers
will be accountable for their decisions
that they made back in august
of this year
well he was apparently your client was
also
questioned by the judge over
something
completely unrelated to this case watch
the judge has asked lieutenant colonel
sheller about a number of statements
that he's made in the past that may have
been in several cases praising or at
least complementary to the protesters on
january 6 at the capitol now colonel
sheller said that these things were
taken out of context that these were
offhand conversations
what
how was that in order how was that
relevant how was that even
possibly
related to this uh conversation
at all nothing
has nothing whatever to do with what
what we were trying to do there in court
that rabbit trail that that the marine
corps tried to run down ended up with
nothing obviously lieutenant colonel
sheller had nothing to do with any of
that
the issue before the court now is
what his punishment will be and i'm
expecting a letter of reprimand
other news today tony is that the
military is going to continue
with its quote extreme vetting
of all members of the armed forces
and saying that automatic alerts will
flag records
or activities of concern
among all defense department personnel
extreme vetting of our troops
i don't even know what that means i mean
you know i was a captain in the marine
corps
um we do have a first amendment
um you know he lieutenant colonel
sheller spoke out and he uh put himself
forward and was accountable for it
uh to suggest uh
that sort of action it makes me wonder
why anybody would want to serve uh you
know the marine corps is strong it's the
the best fighting force that's ever
existed
it's still strong i think a lot of
marines
who heard and saw what lieutenant
colonel sheller did they agreed with him
but they also see that he's taken
accountability for his actions and i'm
still you know are calling on the
general staff
to take some accountability for your
actions here's a man that has not only
lost his retirement his command his job
uh you know his he's he's lost a lot
more things you know laying aside you
know a week in the brig
this has been an emotional roller
coaster for him and for him to stand
forward and and
accept his punishment
like a honorable marine says a lot about
him
he should get an honorable discharge 17
years in the marine corps multiple tours
of duty
it's ridiculous tony thank you hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else